hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
september 7th
2020 what's going on how are
you how's it going oh i'm in a good mood
i'm in a good [ __ ] mood baby
for a bunch of reasons all right number
one
the heat wave heat wave the [ __ ] heat
wave is over
it's only [ __ ] going to be 90 degrees
today it got up to 116 degrees 119
degrees
out here in the [ __ ] valley and i was
sitting there you know all these people
like on on uh
instagram attack i got like both my air
conditioners on
and i want to be like well if there's
any way you could only have
one on you know people who cranked their
[ __ ] acs yesterday
you know i get if you look if you got a
window one and it's just
yeah i get that but [ __ ] rich [ __ ]
all right people who got money who just
still said [ __ ] it and kept their entire
goddamn
place you know you know i kind of got
into it my wife a little bit yesterday i
was just like look let's just have the
[ __ ] ac on
stay on this floor and we'll just shut
it off
you know on the bottom floor
what if i have to go down there then
[ __ ] turn it on
it's 119 degrees out because of people
you know because
partly because of us can we can we just
can we just [ __ ] agree on that
this was the hottest day i've ever
experienced
in my life this weekend was just like it
was
i can't even describe the level of
[ __ ] hot that it was it was just uh
it was 120 [ __ ] goddamn degrees
um but fortunately california's passed
the law i guess in a couple years all
the trucks have to be electric
um so i i just my fear is that we're
moving way too god damn slow
it's unbelievable it's really [ __ ]
amazing to me
the [ __ ] decisions that human beings
will make
with just when money is involved like
well i mean it's this is going to be
great for your children yeah but is it
going to cost 40 dollars more i forget i
ain't [ __ ] doing that i'm not doing
that like this this
um and there really is no solution to it
i've just there's just no way
to get people out of this [ __ ]
mindset
and it's just because i really believe
in my heart of hearts
that um crazy people are attracted to
power
and nice people don't want power so then
what ends up happening
is nice people end up working for slash
listening
to crazy people okay i don't think you
have to look too far
into our leadership right now to
literally find an absolute like
a legit crazy person a [ __ ] crazy
person
and then you're seeing people ignoring
that the dude is crazy i'm not talking
mike pence i love that guy
that guy looks like [ __ ] race bannon
from [ __ ]
uh johnny quest
that guy looks like he's got his [ __ ]
marbles
together but people are so into their
ideologies and their [ __ ] pocketbooks
that they they will look past anything
i mean i this is like just as far as
just you know watch being
in the public eye a little bit and
watching my friends who are in it more
than i am watching them
handle [ __ ] when all of a sudden they
get in trouble i
i just as a [ __ ] person who's a
little bit out there
i'd have to see how donald trump is
going i think he's already handled it
like you would think that calling the
troops
a bunch of suckers and losers that that
especially when your fan base
is is patriotic and so many of of
of the troops are republican
republican families and that type of
[ __ ] how the [ __ ] he's going to get
himself out of this
um i think he's gonna do what he always
does he's gonna lie he's gonna say it's
fake news
and i think the people on the right have
just so bought into this guy that
they're just they're just gonna look
past it they're not going to give a [ __ ]
you know it's it's like sports fans
except this actually counts
so i don't know what i would feel a lot
better
if trump was out of the picture and it
was mike pence first joe bite and then
i'd be like all right these are two you
know
level-headed guys you know and they are
they just have different political
ideologies and you just have to get out
of your own
[ __ ] [ __ ] to see that but jeez
louise this [ __ ] guy this other
[ __ ] guy
um you know i don't he's just a [ __ ]
guy
he's she's just a bullshitter what is
that guy talk it's like he's trying to
sell me a [ __ ] car
um then the other guy if he could quit
spooning with children i think he'd have
a [ __ ] chance right i mean i just
thought
what is he doing i don't know it's a
it's a crazy goddamn time but you know
it's also a great time because it's it's
september 7th
we are three days away from
put it up the nfl starting back up again
you're gonna get to see tom brady
with gronkowski back in new uniforms
down in tampa bay
all right you're going to be able to see
the guy that we got
i'm once the i got to wait till the
season starts you know what the [ __ ]
says cam newton
with bill belichick one's in the nfc the
others in the afc they're on a collision
course and oh by the way
let's not disrespect the [ __ ]
returning the defending super bowl
champions
patrick mahomes are the kansas city
chiefs
you know i think that they're gonna have
a chip on their shoulder being like whoa
wait a minute how come we're not the
story we're the returning champions
and you guys are gonna try to sell this
hatfield of mccoy [ __ ] without us
so i'm looking for them to come out
feeling disrespected i'm looking for
kelsey to dance
even more than he normally does when he
gains a yard and a half
stomping all around the field uh okay
um not really though um
but if i do play fantasy football i'm
definitely drafting that guy
um it's probably too late to start isn't
it
i don't know i don't know bill maybe if
you [ __ ] played it you know some more
more of the goddamn players um anyway
i'm very excited about that and i'm also
excited because the
uh new york islanders beat the
philadelphia flyers i really enjoyed
that
i have this weird relationship with uh
philly sports teams is i like
all of their teams it's just their fans
are such
[ __ ] that it just like i went one time
i went to a boston bruins game i took my
mother
to the fleet set up to watch the bruins
against the flyers
and these three [ __ ] philly fans sat
behind us
and they were such rude [ __ ]
and they knew they were doing it and
they knew it was bugging me which made
him do it even more
that i just i just take joy
i just take joy in the fact that that
those three guys are [ __ ] miserable
right now
and this song goes out to you have you
ever seen the flyers win the cup
have you ever seen the flyers win the
cup if you have you must be crying
because you know you're close to dying
have you ever seen the flyers win the
cup
joe bartnik taught me that song and i
will sing it
i don't know 45 years in
yeah do you realize what that means that
means if you were 45 years old the last
time the flyers won it you're probably
[ __ ] dead
um most likely you're dead i mean that's
that's some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
can you imagine you're a little 12 year
old kid oh boy oh boy they won back to
back oh this is going to be amazing now
i'm 13. they won it again this is what
my life's gonna be
and now you're almost 60 years old
and i'll tell you it could not have
happened to a nicer fan base
i do love the flyers though i do love
those colors
and i do love the way that they played
all those years beating the [ __ ] out of
people i loved it
uh they're fans though it's just you
just
you just like you want to feel bad for
them but then you get around and be like
nah these people
they they kind of deserve it
i mean the [ __ ] 1983 philadelphia
76ers
is my favorite nba team of all time
i [ __ ] love that team and i
like i said i've been saying it forever
i put them up against the 96 bulls
um that now that i think that that's the
greatest match-up come on moses
cheat maurice cheeks dr j andrew tony
um i would that put bill cunningham up
against phil jackson i would do it
um just that foregone conclusion that
they would just beat anybody i just i
just i don't buy it
um moses malone down low against [ __ ]
uh
what the [ __ ] was the guy's name uh not
luke walton
who they had they had they had uh
it was luke something or other big goofy
white guy he would have got dunked on
the whole goddamn [ __ ]
series um whatever shut the [ __ ] up bill
okay can you even hit a layup no i can't
i just like talking [ __ ] um i missed the
f1 race yesterday
that was evidently the one that i wanted
to see
let me finish talking [ __ ] uh hockey
here so the islanders since the first
time since 1993
uh the last time the the canadians won a
uh stanley cup and the last time a
canadian team won a stanley cup which is
why
i was rooting for vancouver
because uh you know canada gave us this
great game every [ __ ] year they come
in
it's like it's seven teams against 23.
it's getting ridiculous although it's
been a 30-year drought so one of you
[ __ ] should have won it by now
um and you know what's better than
seeing
canadian people happy you know
because then they can continue with the
lie
of that country being progressive and
open
to oh to like i don't know whatever
they're supposed to be like they always
make them out like
whenever i go up there they always tease
them like do you guys think like you're
like the best white people
you know when you have the exact same
[ __ ] history we do
you know
so um anyway yeah
philadelphia flyers 45-year drought
vancouver canucks
lose to the vegas knights they've never
won it they've been in the league since
50-year drought buffalo sabres 50-year
drought and then the leaders
of them all is the uh
toronto maple leafs 53-year drought a
special uh
mention to the california golden seals
that later on became the cleveland
barons who never won anything and then
folded
you know at least these other teams are
still out there
you know the kansas city scouts are
still out there via colorado rockies and
now they're the new jersey devils and
then they ended up winning something and
i wonder if anybody in kansas city even
realized it there's probably a couple of
die-hard [ __ ]
scout fans out there that were happy in
1995.
all right bill you've you've you've
established that you're you have no life
and all you've been doing is watching
sports
and i missed the the italian grand prix
formula one race yes
yesterday congratulations to pierre
gasly i think i taped it i have to watch
it um
you know if you asked me to say that
guy's name i wouldn't have known it
because he's always in the
the back of the pack middle of the field
or whatever just because you know
mercedes has all the [ __ ] money
and uh these other teams can't get
enough money to compete it's not
mercedes fault
it's nobody's [ __ ] fault i don't know
they got to do like revenue sharing or
something like they do in football
because if you look at like if you're a
new orleans fan
right you watch the saints every year
you're like we got a shot winning the
super bowl
you go to a pelicans game it's like
let's go see zion while he's still here
we all knew anthony davis was going to
[ __ ] we uh you just
know that like eventually if you have
one of the best players in the league
and you're in new orleans or you're in
charlotte or orlando
eventually they're just going to end up
on the lakers that's how they do their
business over there i don't get it
which is why i'm absolutely thrilled
with the miami heat play in the way that
they're playing even though they finally
lost
as long as a team as long as the lakers
don't win it i've i
i've just given in to the [ __ ] pylon
team and i've kind of given into the
fact
that we're the celtics are always going
to be on the outside looking in when it
comes to that just simply
because of what we're offering versus
what the lakers can offer
the lakers can offer uh let's see the
celtics will offer
humidity winter
uh women average is probably a six in
over-the-top racism
where la can offer a dry heat
uh 12 months out of the year except 120
degrees that might be tipping in our
favor
uh you can bang movie stars and models
and uh over-the-top racism
we're not going to win that fight lebron
the anthony davises
the kobe bryant's the shacks the phil
jacksons they're
gonna go to la
they don't want to button up after a
game they want they want to unbutton
their [ __ ] their shirt down to their
navel
and wade into that sea of [ __ ] top
shelf [ __ ] that's what they want to do
we can't offer that in boston we can't
compete
although we're doing a hell of a job
danny ainge working with what he has to
work we're doing a hell of a job
and uh you know we bought one
championship you know every every team
gets lucky
we bought it in 2008 took a page out of
the lakers [ __ ]
playbook if you can't draft it buy it
um yeah i just uh one of my favorite
things over the last couple of years was
listening to laker fans complaining
about kevin durant going to [ __ ]
the warriors it's like hey now you know
how everybody else feels
watching kobe shack and phil jackson all
going out there
i mean that was [ __ ] ridiculous
they [ __ ] he should have stayed in
[ __ ] orlando kobe should have stayed
with charlotte
phil jackson i mean i guess they i mean
they're just being [ __ ] they let him go
but i mean i don't
i know know that this that whole [ __ ]
thing was stupid i'm just sitting there
watching it going this is not
this is not competition this is just the
best people in the league all on the
same team and then they're all walking
around you know
miming putting a ring on the whole
[ __ ] thing i don't know
i don't know and i can i can you know i
have to be honest with you
that 2008 celtic team i hated that team
we were in last place the year before
then all of a sudden we just have all of
these guys
i mean it was fun when we went up
against the [ __ ] stacked lakers
and beat him arguably get beat him again
the next year except they called 58
fouls on us
um i don't know i like i like the
uh you know i like the way the nfl does
it that's
i i like that you know nhl does it right
and the mlb you know they kind of came
around
it's like all right well if the red sox
and yankees can have 200 million dollar
roided up free agent team
then the astros should be allowed to
bang on a trash can i mean that just
makes sense to me
you got to do something to try and level
it out but this whole [ __ ] [ __ ]
that
you know if you're a new orleans
pelicans fan you got to sit there and go
to every [ __ ] game because you know
zion's going to leave when his first
rookie contract is over you know he's
going to leave what do you think he's
going to go
you know what i would love the vegas
odds let me see if i can find vegas odds
of zion ending up on the lakers you know
it just seems like that's where
it's i mean i'm telling you the dry heat
the level of [ __ ] okay
zion williamson
odds of being a
laker okay the truth about
the lakers chance it's i see it's
already a thing in 2019
it was already stephen a talks zion's uh
chances lakers let's see what are the
lakers odds this is all okay so this
almost happened already
oh that was the draft i'm sorry i don't
know [ __ ] sorry about that
um okay free agent let me put in free
agent
come on this i'm gonna as many search
words as i need to so i can become right
okay and you know what my internet
mercifully cocked out all right i'll
have a fun bet with you guys
i don't know how to make the bet but i'm
saying that i'm gonna go out on a limb
here and say that that guy ends up being
a laker
huh you want to take that bet huh
um let's see i just got a text here oh
look at this that's
i actually got a text on some travel for
the dates i have coming up i actually
have stand-up dates coming up i'm gonna
make
some money in 2020
um yes i will be at uh
some farm in [ __ ] connecticut and
then i'm gonna be some other outdoor
venue
i believe kevin hart was there this
weekend in new jersey so
uh i don't know i'm gonna go knock out a
bunch of shows
i'm very excited um
i've been looking around i don't know
some of these i'm hoping like
because the east coast seems to know how
to do these shows
which means eventually the midwest and
the west coast the south everybody else
pacific northwest they're all going to
figure out how to do it and i'm just
going to have to do
like what i used to do rather than doing
one big show i'm just gonna have to do
like
uh you know 10 12 shows but you know
what
i have i i haven't worked for five six
months so i can't wait to do it i can
i can't even tell you guys how [ __ ]
excited i
am to bring my big stupid [ __ ] head
back out onto this
on to the stage and uh tell some jokes i
cannot
[ __ ] wait it's it's it's the only
thing that i
i really well it's not the only thing i
want to play drums fly helicopters but i
mean it's
it's it's way up there on the list no
honestly i can't wait to get the [ __ ]
back out there
and um start talking [ __ ] again making
people laugh
and uh i gotta be honest with you i i
really
was something that i was doing before
and i will continue to do
is that i'm just going to go be
more over the top and more ridiculous
more absurd than i've ever been
um because um i just
you know i'm just seeing
people that who aren't even good at
stand-up are of
having this effect on what people can
and can't talk about and you would think
that wouldn't you have to be good at it
first
that would be like me as shitty as i am
at playing drums telling people what
fills they can and can't play what time
signatures they can play in
it's [ __ ] ridiculous so um
i don't know and i've been it's kind of
been fun as a comic to push back against
that type of [ __ ] you know
and i know as much as some people will
drive away during the show
whatever the [ __ ] that's all about i
mean it just it is what it is it's going
to be a good time so
anyway um let me uh
let me move on here do a little bit of
advertising here
little advertisements all right helix
helix
everybody uh don't read aloud insert
reasons you could have
a hard time sleeping we don't read a lot
i read everything that's that's here
i i like that question why wouldn't i
want to read that aloud this is like uh
the family feud
we asked a hundred people uh give me a
reason why you'd have a hard time
sleeping
uh
uh what do you got uh bird family uh
terminal erection and you sleep on your
stomach show me terminal erections
bing number two answer um
well uh stress
uh no air conditioner
um you're in a motel and your door opens
right out into the parking lot
a car just pulled up and you hear
arguing
sorry going back into my road days there
um
the person you're with snores too loud
you're uncomfortable
your mattress is is not hard enough it's
it's it's too firm and there's got to be
a zillion reasons
i don't know why we have to keep that
[ __ ] question to private all right
helix oh they spelt it out for me helix
sleeps makes personalized mattresses
made right here in america
that's right man weed and mastresses
nobody does it better
and ship straight to your door with with
free
no contact delivery free returns and a
hundred night sleep trial
gross uh to choose a mattress helix
made a quiz that takes just two minutes
to complete and matches your body type
and sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you
um if you like a mattress that that's
really soft or firm
you sleep on your side or on your back
or on your stomach or you sleep really
hot
with with helix there's a specific
mattress for
for each and everybody's unique taste i
love helix
but you don't need to take my word for
it helix was awarded the number one best
overall mattress pick of 2020. that's
this year everybody if you're keeping
score
by gq magazine wired magazine
and apartment therapy just go to
helixsleep.com burr
take their two-minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress you're like a king
that will keep you uh that would give
you the best sleep of your life they
have a 10-year
warranty and you get to try out
try it out for a hundred nights risk
free
they'll even pick it up gross and give
you a full refund if you don't love it
but you will right now helix is offering
up to 200
off mattress orders for our listeners
get up to 200
off at helixsleep.com h-e-l-i-x
sleep.com oh look who's back everybody
it's my bookie hey how you doing how the
[ __ ] you doing all right all right my
bookie everybody winning season returns
at my bookie winning seasons means
doubling your first deposit winning
season means
free bets insane props and nfl survivor
streaks
at my bookie oh my god i can't wait for
football season
three days away winning season means
free entry into the hundred thousand
dollar guaranteed
super contest during week one of the nfl
season play in my bookies 100 000
guarantee super contest uh for free
it's easy pick five games against the
spread each week
earn points for wins and ties score the
most points at the end of the season
and win 25 grand quarterly
125 grand quarterly winners will take
home
five grand plus the top 750 scores
share a hundred thousand dollars in cash
and prizes for free
um add more excitement
uh to the games you love with this epic
season-long super contest and don't
forget on thursday september 10th
the reigning super bowl 54 champion
kansas city chief
what off uh the nfl season as a ten
point favorite over the houston texans
to celebrate their championship and the
return of football
my bookie is boosting the line to um
plus 54 for a limited time only
all right uh use promo code bird to
double your content
your deposit and grab a free entry into
the biggest online handicapping
uh super contest on the net your winning
season begins today exclusively at my
bookie it'll [ __ ] you knowing
um oh my god i can't wait to watch that
every
[ __ ] down of that game i cannot wait
i cannot wait
honey could you no i cannot
you know what this is what you got to do
you got to talk to your laugh right now
and just say listen sweetheart you're
the love of my life
but come all right 7 8 p.m
this thursday east coast time it's like
i don't even know you for the next three
hours and i want you to be okay with
that
all right go take a late late late
brunch
you know or go get dinner go upstairs go
downstairs but get
the [ __ ] away from me unless you're is
as excited about this as i am and then
if that's the case we could we can watch
together and and bang during halftime
all right um um
oh this is i guess we're done with the
reads we're going geez we're jumping
right into it here
we're jumping right into it i thought
the next advertisement was called the
cast system
and i was like ah that's that doesn't
sound that sounds like that's a weird
name for a company
unless they're uh this is like
invisalign like you know that do it at
your home
invisalign if they had the cast system
like do-it-yourself cast
you know you're tired of breaking your
limbs and having to go down to the
doctor to let this son of a [ __ ]
uh a highfalutin uh superior elitist guy
set your bones back in place wouldn't it
be great if there's a home system
well thankfully there is the caste
system
next time you blow out your your knee
trying to catch a [ __ ] grease pig
all right the cast system everybody uh
hey billy
no brahman i don't know what that means
i gotta look that b
r a right
b b-r-a-h-i-m
brahman this thing is uh
that's a [ __ ] soccer player
brahm diaz uh
brown bags shop for brown bags online at
macy's
what the [ __ ] is a brahm bag i don't get
it i like when you guys insult me that's
worse when i just said billy no brainer
no brainer having i don't know jesus
bill just read it okay
hey billy no brahim brahman uh
i'm not from india but i do read oh
jesus christ but i do play an indian
on tv so hear me out uh on the last
monday morning podcast you wondered why
indians are still
casting it up even after the fall of the
british
raj the simplest answer now i'm taking
all of this
with a uh oh wait a minute is that like
a
birkum bag
because the purses just showed up i
don't know
plowing ahead uh the simplest answer is
that india's caste system
predates british colonial colonialism by
3000 years
oh really so the british are off the
hook for that
and you're not indian but i'll take your
word for it until somebody indian writes
in
its historical roots can be traced back
to the second millennium
bce following the conquest of the
northern
half of the subcontinent by the
so-called
aryans yeah those aryans as with the
swastika symbol of hindu
and antiquity and the charlie chaplin
style narrow mustache of the early 20th
century
yeah that nazi symbol they actually
stole that and they made it they turned
it into something bad and we're all
just waiting for the lead singer of
youtube bono
to take it back you know he already did
it with helter skelter
long time ago somebody took this song
tonight
we're going to take it back
you didn't take it back it's still
linked with charlie manson but good on
you
you and your ego thinking that that was
enough to take it back
um nonetheless way back when
there was indeed a group of
step nomads steep nomads who conquered
large swaths of eastern europe
along with the modern day iran in
northern india
i believe it was called persia back then
right uh think of them as the first
mongols nice
good for them but how do we know
but how do we know about them apart from
the studying their descendant languages
i'll get to that in a second i love that
you thought i was smart enough to ask
that question
so ignoring about 30 centuries of
history let's jump to the middle of the
19th
uh at the height of the british empire
and wonder
not why did the british impose the caste
system but rather why didn't they
abolish it again the simplest answer is
convenience
ruling a population of 200 million
people on the other side of the world
is no easy feat better to graft the
necessary administrations onto the
already existing customs
that try to replace them than rather
than try to place them wholesale right
uh of cour well yeah if they're
oppressing each other
and you want to impress them as a group
yeah just leave what they have in place
of course modern scholars have taken the
brits to task for code
codifying india's caste system and
implementing it in their colonial laws
and have even argued that the caste
system wasn't nearly as rigid
before british rule they argued this in
neutrality titled books
like the scandal of empire indian and
the creation of the imperial
britain so you're saying that they're
incredibly biased books
all right this guy is really smart and
i'm almost i'm not getting most of these
jokes all right unfortunately
they're full of [ __ ] uh well according
to you
okay grade a academic horse [ __ ] to be
precise
which brings us back to the aryans how
do we know they established india's
caste system
because their descendants still rule it
and we can code
for their genes according to david reich
a geneticist at harvard and the leading
researchers in the ante
in the ancient population dna sequencing
the strongest signals of elevated steep
ancestry were in two groups
that were of traditionally priestly
status who were expected to be
custodians of text written in
sanskrit i hope i'm saying this [ __ ]
right uh the people who are custodians
of the indo-european language and
culture were the ones
with relatively more steep ancestry and
because of the extraordinary strength of
the caste system
in preserving ancestry in social roles
over generations
the ancient substructure in the
annie ancestral north indians is
the a-a-n-n-i i guess is evident in some
of today's
brahmins even after thousands of years
oh so brahmins are actually people i
thought they were purses
because that's what came up when i did a
search or a soccer player in other words
there's a reason the brilliant
gastroenterologist dr
sidden hartha is this just a whole
trolling [ __ ] question just to
expose how much i can't read uh comes
from the same country as the untouchable
sewer cleaner
sanjay and it's not because the british
forced them to pay
attention to their [ __ ] all right so
he's saying basically it
was already there and was implemented
by the so-called aryans yeah those
aryans
as with the swastika symbol on hindu inc
antiquity charlie chapston the early
20th century all right
okay well that's that's interesting i i
think i need to read more than that i
mean i
i'd have to read that another ten times
to understand most of that um but from
what you're saying was it basically
already existed and then they just
worked with it and now people are giving
them [ __ ] for not abolishing it
while they oppress people um is that
what it was
is that what just happened there i i
have no idea what just happened there
um all right twitter [ __ ]
all right hey bill saw this tweet and it
made me think of you i'm starting to
believe we're a country of suckers
falling for the oddest crumble society
play in the
book love you love the podcast all right
somebody tweeted
having traveled across the u.s over the
last two months
new place every week coast to coast it's
terrifying
ex all in capitals to see how twitter
adjusts
its news and spin based
on your location even if it knows your
personal algorithm
affects everything from which comment
you see
first oh wow to adds
to what's trending i always knew this
information
approach was a thing but to experience
that dramatic
a shift from state to state in such a
relatively short amount of time
was incredibly eye-opening uh
who is reading what and why well that
would explain yeah the divide
i think yeah social media 24-hour news
networks like cnn and fox news
uh they've pitted us all against one
another
um and uh
i i it's how you think it's working out
everybody
i i don't think it's i don't think it's
been a good thing we can't even get on
the same page with the goddamn
virus that's affecting all of us killing
all of our grandparents you know
potentially um
yeah i don't know that it's done
i think it's done for monetary reasons
though i don't think it's done to divide
i just think that you know
um the greed of just going after the
dollar
and not wanting to piss people off and
just
giving people what they want to hear or
you think that they want to hear i think
that they're doing it because
of that and but then you combine the
fact with
when you go on the internet like me
right now like you don't have need to
have any qualifications whatsoever
and if you deliver something with
confidence people believe that it's true
especially if they want it to be true so
it's very uh
very crazy so what you could do is like
you could be like me and just completely
tap out
it's weird i'm on social media but i'm
not really paying attention
there's a few comics i follow obviously
but i mean i pretty much watch
stuff i watch musicians
i watch animals fighting each other you
know bear vs moose i watch all of that
[ __ ]
um i watch
uh a lot of [ __ ] on old
cars and pickup trucks specifically
motorcycles
racing and what i hate is if i try and
do anything about
fitness then the next time i go
into my search it's all [ __ ] booty
models
and all of that and then i look like
i've been watching [ __ ] porn which i
haven't been doing since may and i don't
even think about it anymore
i think i was addicted to porn for the
better part of 20 [ __ ] years
once it became free you know it's like
when you first move out
you know and you're like wait i can go
to the grocery store and buy what i want
to buy and you start buying bags of
oreos
i can have as many as i want you know
that's what like free porn was
it was the [ __ ] porn version of the
porn version of that
um but i gotta tell you uh
it's a great thing it's a great thing it
sucks for like three weeks
because you gotta [ __ ] reboot your
brain like did i actually have the
ability to uh
use my brain to uh
come up with different scenarios when
the computer's been doing this for me
yeah like that part of my brain
got lazy um
so i don't know maybe that was an
overshare but i'm just saying you can
get off porn
i even got uncomfortable halfway through
i was trying to figure out how to word
it
uh i don't know what to think about if i
want to jerk off because you've been
doing it for me that's what i was
basically trying to say there we go that
was the streamline
all right flyover states my favorites
my favorite my favorite my favorite
um
anyway oh somebody's gonna criticize the
seinfeld act am i gonna do that first
let me do this one first seinfeld
article
yo billy nubnub star wars look it up
may felt okay all right i'll look it up
right now
what is a nub nub that's probably an
adorable little creature or some sort of
robot
uh here we go
star wars
nub nub
yubnub is one this guy wrote nubnub
what does yubnub mean
freedom oh jesus all right
uh that seinfeld article was a great
cheerleading effort to get new york city
to believe
it will be what it was not saying it
won't but the article he responded to
wasn't that harsh it was realistic
um listen we all know that people are
struggling but if you're going to go on
public record
basically you're going to say out to the
public that though i'm leaving the whole
the whole city's going down the [ __ ]
drain
uh here's a real number 75 of all
restaurants in new york will be out of
business by spring of next year
even with the booming holiday season
which they won't
uh which they won't get it wouldn't be
enough
the mayor of new york said in response
to things being shut down
uh the rich will have
well how are you miss come on guys you
gotta you gotta proofread these i guess
the rich
will have to order takeout that that's
ignorant political [ __ ] i have four
friends who have already had to shut
down
two are owners of two separate
restaurants and the other yeah buddy
we all know we're going through
difficult times
it was just great for somebody to say
we're going to be back well let me ask
you this these people who are going are
they never going to own a restaurant
again
are they never going to work again okay
we've gone through [ __ ] like this
in the past and all he was saying is
that i mean god forbid somebody says
something
positive and now what you're gonna do is
just go all
negative and just say that you're being
a realist
um seinfeld was also being a realist
he wasn't sitting in the middle of this
say acting like this was the end of the
[ __ ] world
and that new york city as we know it is
is done and over and
it's it's never going to be you know
you're never going to be able to open
another [ __ ] restaurant all right
i i all of this [ __ ] that you know and
love that's going away
when it was built there was people
bitching going but you you're tearing
down this other thing that we knew and
loved
and then that becomes the new thing all
right when the world trade centers were
first built people [ __ ] hated them
they hated them and then they became the
identity of the skyline and then when we
lost them
people were beyond sad
all right it's just whatever you love
took the place of something
that somebody else loved okay we're all
going through a rough [ __ ] time here
and why do i need to read all of these
[ __ ] depressing stats
that that this this what you're gonna do
is what the news has been doing this is
all they've been doing
that's why i like what seinfeld wrote
all right he says that's ignorant
political [ __ ]
i have four friends who've already had
to shut down two are owners of two
separate restaurants
and the other two each manage other
places all out of work three are leaving
the city aside from banking
food is everything when it comes to the
city's economy
it's fine to be optimistic but saying
new york is the greatest city in the
world
doesn't change how [ __ ] bleak it's
been well you missed his message
trash is literally piling up like it's
never never before that's [ __ ]
the garbage men went on strike it was
way worse
everything is going to continue to go to
[ __ ] for as long as it takes huge real
estate groups to come in
and buy up the whole blocks you should
really look into it more
i understand all of this sir
i understand all of this but it was just
nice to read something positive
thank you for bringing me back down into
the you're so [ __ ] real
man i mean you're catastrophizing here
is what you're doing you're acting as
though first of all you're saying that
the
trash has never piled up like this
before that's complete [ __ ]
the city was damn near lights out
late 70s early 80s it was going bankrupt
you could there was like people
squatting in empty [ __ ] buildings
that you could have bought for nothing
and now look at them they're worth
zillions of dollars
i remember when i first moved to like
harlem i mean i first went to new york
city
and i take the bus and we'd go through
harlem it still looked like the way new
york looked back and now look at it
no one would ever said that it would
have came back like that all right it's
constantly [ __ ] changing
and i know jennifer gentrification
people don't like that [ __ ] i'm not
i'm pro or against it but like those
white people also got pushed out of
where they were
everybody's getting pushed everything
moves everything changes it doesn't have
to be
the end of the [ __ ] world okay this
is
you know my big worry is that
our money in our whole financial system
is nothing but a ponzi scheme
and that they will look at this virus as
a skate as the scapegoat they needed
to gracefully walk away and blame kovid
in political parties and that type of
[ __ ] for why the dollar collapsed
rather than the fact that they were a
bunch of greedy [ __ ]
all right anyway
but i i just i don't know he says i i do
agree with you we don't have any good
leaders
but also can you acknowledge that this
isn't just some recession stuff this is
a whole new thing
that's happening to the city it's not a
new thing new
you missed the point new york has gone
through this
when seinfeld moved to new york the city
was bankrupt
there was no curb your dog lost it was
dog [ __ ] all over the place
when i first came to new york dude you
wouldn't even you wouldn't [ __ ]
alphabet city
was you didn't go there day or night
thompson square park was totally taken
over by [ __ ] drug addicts homeless
people and all of that type of [ __ ]
like stuff does change um
it's not always just gonna be for the
worse and
and there's two ways of living your life
you can just sit there and be like oh it
used to be better
and now it sucks and it's never gonna
get better you can live like that
or you can think positively about the
future whereas i'm sitting out here
in the throes of global warming with
1920 degree [ __ ] weekend here
i was holding on to the fact that
california passed a law that all trucks
have got to be [ __ ] electric in the
next couple of years um
and i think you know it's going to be a
tough transition and i believe that
we're going to do it
i also believe that they're going to
come up with some quick testing is going
to be more affordable
they're going to come up with some sort
of vaccine you know
if aids didn't take us out this thing
isn't going to take us out we're going
to lose a lot of
restaurants there'll be a bunch of new
ones that come in
and you know as far as corporations and
big real estate groups buying [ __ ] up
they've been doing that forever
and but there's still always going to be
cool parts of the [ __ ] city
and uh i believe in people i believe in
the this country
and i approve of this message all right
there you go so
onward and upward all right i'm 38 she's
19.
oh jesus and pregnant oh jesus
christ jesus christ
all right when you were banging her were
you still wearing your high school
football jacket that you can't button
anymore
oh god all right hey yo billy bloodnut
uh josh here from sydney australia uh
one of my favorite [ __ ] countries out
there
i love australia i've been there forever
um i need the advice of the world's
greatest copper wire
pubes owner well that would be me um
i'm a 38 year old man who's been seeing
a 19 year old
stunner stannah um
all right well i don't know what the uh
that would be frowned upon here
you know i mean people did it i mean
people always made fun of that [ __ ]
all right i don't know i don't know how
it works over there all right we met at
the gym
i'll never forget the day she walked in
the second i saw her my heart skipped a
beat as she put down her book bag i'm
kidding
my heart skipped a beat and i froze
amazing face
[ __ ] me eyes tiny waist and a fat ass
that hips thrust 200 kilograms jesus
this guy
is a [ __ ] creep
um i've never had a problem speaking
with women to be honest i [ __ ] roughly
1 000 women in my years with
a few serious relationships in between
you've had serious relationships while
[ __ ] a thousand you must have been
[ __ ] those women right through those
relationships
i couldn't even say hello to this girl
for three months the whole time i
thought she was 26
i changed gyms for a week and every day
all day within that week i felt like it
would be my life's regret
if i didn't say hello i swallowed my
fears
probably from building her up in my head
that three months
and went back to the gym and finally
said hello hello her response
was the same as my energy she had been
waiting for me to say hello that whole
time
uh the next day we went for dinner and
cocktails i found out she
she was 19 an influencer with over 200
000 follower pretty good for an aussie
chick and had been living between sydney
and la for a couple of years
needless to say using the words of the
great dave chappelle
i beat the [ __ ] up you know i got to
get you know i got to tip my cap to how
unfiltered this guy is
murphy's law has it
that she falls pregnant
i don't think that's murphy's law buddy
i think that's the law of nature
if you don't wear a condom and she's not
barren
and you [ __ ] bust in or yeah that
that could happen that's not murphy's
law dude
let's not blame the irish for this one
too all right we came to
uh to the decision not to go through
with it
over the weeks she went to to scans so
they can determine dates and when to do
the deed over the time
at that time she grew attached to the
pregnancy by seeing the heartbeat
yeah and the pictures exactly and
ultimately decided to keep it
well good for her um
over the weeks in that meantime i
struggled with the age difference
oh now you struggle with the age do you
never [ __ ] struggle when you [ __ ]
busted a nutner
the major reason being i have a
five-year-old son to one woman
and an 18 year old daughter to another
this guy is a [ __ ] piece of work
uh they're the same age your older
daughter yes the same age
uh billy big balls what the [ __ ] do i do
well there's nothing you can do you
gotta because my
daughter doesn't know well you gotta
tell her i've told my besties
and they're they're all like bro you're
the king
this is just reading like this isn't
real i i
they didn't go like bro you just [ __ ]
your life
uh but i feel like a dud and a bad
father
um i'd say you definitely have some sort
of issues you might want to go to
therapy if this is true
and see why you're banging a thousand
women and
[ __ ] you got a five-year-old with
this one an eighteen-year-old that one
now you're gonna have one with this 19
year old
um yeah i would definitely say you got
some sort of commitment issues or
something i don't know what but it's
gonna cost you if you weren't my country
dude you'd be [ __ ] broke
uh if my daughter was seeing a dude my
age it would be the last day she saw him
alive
okay so
all right so so are you acknowledging
that you were a bit of a dirt bag here
uh but god damn what would a bald
emaciated viking like yourself do
uh i would raise that kid and i'd start
wearing a [ __ ] condom is what i would
do stay blessed stay healthy stay being
awesome every day
listener to something of your work for
years now
yeah buddy uh listen dude you got to get
your dick under control
your dick is [ __ ] your life up uh you
don't have control over it
and your dick is deciding what you're
gonna do rather than your brain because
if you looked at all of that on paper
if you talk to the younger you now i
know you love your kids and everything
okay didn't you you wanted to find
i don't think that you wanted to have a
bunch of kids with a bunch of different
women
um i mean that makes it really
difficult but i mean it is your life so
what i would do is i would
man up to what you did i would tell my
daughters about it
i'd go to therapy if you feel if you
agree with what i'm saying i would start
wearing a condom
um and uh
you know i try to
get with women my own age or within
reason
you know what i mean i mean okay i'll go
with the fact you thought she was 26 but
when you found out she was 19 not only
do you still go
oh you i guess you found on the date you
still bang her
you bust a nutner i mean those were
you know what's the nicest way of saying
really [ __ ] stupid moves um
yeah buddy what are you doing man i'm
getting stressed reading this whole
[ __ ] thing
um yeah that's what i would do
i mean you just gotta you gotta
you got to raise this kid is what you
got to do
i would i don't know where your now soon
to be three kids live
i would pick an apartment right in the
middle of all of them and i would
dedicate
the next 20 years of my life to making
sure that five-year-old and that
your new kid um
don't have daddy issues so they don't go
to a gym
and bang some 38 year old without a
[ __ ] condom
all right good luck to you brother all
right fly over state
uh dear bill i live in what is often
referred to as a flyover state
i appreciate you defending us and
calling out people who
who use it i [ __ ] love it man
those states are great they're not
overly populated and they're [ __ ]
beautiful dude you give me a
lush green topography with a [ __ ]
lake
you know and no traffic i'm sold
um anyways uh i appreciate you defending
us and calling out people who use it not
so much the phrase but the dismissive
tone
it's used by some the way you talk about
something eventually informs how you
feel about it if you're not careful
i'm not saying everyone in my place of
the world is the most progressive person
you ever met hey dude i live in la
la's not the most progressive place
either including people who think
they're really progressive you can get
so progressive and get [ __ ] crazy and
you go so far the other way you're at a
neo-nazi meeting which i can do all of
that
within [ __ ] a half hour of my house
um
just as many bigots in large cities from
my experience
that is 100 percent true um
they just know uh well i've missed a
sentence i'm not saying every my place
is progressive person you're the most
progressive person you ever meet but
damn
if that's not an ignorant part of the
stereotype
um just as many bigots and large cities
from our experience that has been my
experience
um experience of some of my friends or
whatever it's just like that some of the
wild [ __ ] that people have said
you know i've had said while being in
the middle of nowhere
you know florida chicago everywhere i've
heard it everywhere
uh i just want to let you know that in
my country we
we have my county we have had at least
we've had three cases of covid in the
last three months
zero death since it started and never
had crowded hospitals my mother has
worked
at the largest hospital in the area for
almost 40 years so it's not just some
[ __ ] i read
on the internet we live clean and eat
organic
and all that good stuff without even
trying but what i can tell people in
cities spend lots of money to avoid bad
food yes we do
um we don't need a whole lot
we don't need a whole foods out here
people just give you stuff from their
gardens because they got so much of it
you could say we're almost like
socialists in that manner
yeah we got fast food and bad habits too
but it ain't worse
than jack-in-the-box yak in the box he
said
and whatever else you got to settle on
uh we got third generation burger stands
instead love your podcast yeah that's
awesome man i
i really am uh
i'm sold on it i went on zillow and
looked uh at some places
you know not like i'm i'm not moving but
i'm just was just looking at it every
once in a while if i want to
irritate myself and two of my favorite
places milwaukee
and chattanooga tennessee and i found
this place in chattanooga tennessee
because i always just see what's the
most expensive house i could buy out
here
and i found one out there for like just
under 3 million bucks it was
19 000 square feet
it had a half court of basketball it had
an indoor pool that when they took a
picture of it it looked like you were in
a dated hotel
um the decor needed a little dressing up
but it was [ __ ]
ridiculous the house was huge
you were up on a hill with a view that
house would be a hundred million dollars
out here in l.a
um so there is something
to say about being out there but like um
to be honest with you i just wouldn't
want to be an interracial couple living
in the middle of [ __ ] nowhere because
i just don't need those
those [ __ ] you know the yahoos out
there are pretty [ __ ] scary
so um but having said that
um i'm a huge fan of uh
a bunch of these cities that i've i've
gone to and now i'm actually looking at
even smaller places
and i find the smaller i go the more i
like
last year when i went down to and i went
to the i stayed on that lake
and we went to a uh clemson game
i mean i fell in love with that place
the pace of it the lake
the middle of [ __ ] nowhere people
just leaving you the [ __ ]
alone um
is really just you know
but you know there's also amazing
aspects to living in a city too but like
uh you know
i i kind of like when i was out doing
that uh
that gig in ohio i was really just being
like wow man
i could drive my f-100 around these
country roads
granted i couldn't do it for a number of
months because it's snowing out but who
gives a [ __ ]
just start it up and i'll be fine i
could have a motorcycle out here and not
feel like i was going to die every 10
[ __ ] feet
um you know
i could fly a helicopter out of this
cool ass [ __ ] airport that's not
super busy i mean it was just
a lot fresh air their [ __ ] dairy farm
i mean it was amazing now granted you
know when you just dip in you don't get
like a feel
you know what the school systems and all
of that shit's like but i mean i just
i don't know i i i get why people live
out there
um all right seinfeld article i already
read that one 38 and pregnant
38 and pregnant you know i got all of
that done
um all right what else we got
psychedelics and scatter brain
oh jesus christ buddy i'm afraid to read
this if you tell me that taking
psychedelics helps with you
not being a scatterbrained and then i
end up like [ __ ]
jim the taxi driver all right listen
bill
i heard you said a few podcasts ago not
wanting to try psychedelics because you
already
enough scatter brain you already scatter
brain the lunatic
no i yeah no what i was afraid is that
um with all my crazy [ __ ] thoughts
that i have
not under the influence of that [ __ ] i
don't need it to be walking around in
front of me or whatever happens
he said i'm also a scatter brain lunatic
and it [ __ ] sucks
um depends on the job you pick
uh it's great for comedy the worst is
that i'm so
self-conscious about it and feel like
it's getting in the way of so many
things in my life because i always feel
mentally
different than everybody else so i
decided to try mushrooms
it [ __ ] changed my life for the best
man
by the way um i was going to ask in that
what the hell did i just want to ask i'm
so scatterbrained i literally just
forgot
because i've always felt mentally
different but oh do do you find those
scatter brain as you are
but if something captures your interest
like you just all of a sudden get like
tunnel vision
and become obsessed with it um
because that's kind of how i am all
right after listening to rogan and all
the positive things he's had to say
about psychedelics i figure
i'd give give it a try made sure
the set and the settings was relaxing
and removed any and all distractions
around me swallowed the shrooms and then
meditated
the trip was great with a hint of what
the [ __ ]
uh it really felt like uh
it really felt like cleaning my room but
in my brain
let me organize all these half open
files laying around
and all these heavy harsh feelings on
different things
going on in the media it just put
everything into perspective and let me
reorganize
all these thoughts that take huge
amounts of room in my brain
once the trip was over a few hours later
my brain was spotless
i then went to bed for the night and
had these [ __ ] weird dreams the next
morning i could instantly feel a
difference i could focus
think clearly finish projects and had
2 000 more empathy for people around me
the [ __ ] going on in the world didn't
affect me and i felt 100 percent
back uh to when everything was going
well
i was afraid like you that being
scatterbrained in a cycle would
maybe not mix well with psychedelics
uh he said i've had an addictive
personality also so was afraid of that
but turns out shrooms are not addictive
it's like
a chore and you're exhausted
after a trip it's really like cleaning
your room
and i really suggested especially for
your brain type because i fully relate
to you
i hope you give it a try and keep you
updated okay now go [ __ ] yourself and
try psychedelics all right i'm in i'm
tripping this week i'll let you know how
it goes no i'm kidding
um i just you know i got two kids man i
can't be [ __ ]
like when am i gonna when is it okay for
me to just [ __ ] leave
my responsibility for four hours or six
hours whatever the [ __ ] it takes
um when i'm on the road no
[Music]
i don't know dude uh i've opened a lot
of pandora boxes in my life
and that i wish i remained close i don't
know i'd have to it's going to take more
than
um one [ __ ] email
although i gotta be honest with you i
don't think i've ever let's listen to
somebody who took psychedelics like
mushrooms and ever said anything bad
about them
um anybody have a bad trip anybody let's
hear the other side you know what i mean
i want to hear from trump people explain
to me why i should still have faith in a
guy who says the troops are all suckers
and losers please tell me that
okay explain to me okay but only if
you're going to just address the fact
that the guy did say
okay i mean oh whatever i i can't say
there is the chance that maybe it is a
left-wing conspiracy but you do know
that he did say
to inject household cleaner into you to
try to get rid of the covet
and then they tried to cover him say he
was being facetious because
what a time to be sarcastic during the
middle of a pandemic
um whatever who gives a [ __ ] i know
that's just going to create arguments
all right that's it everybody um
go island i'm rooting for the islanders
and i'm rooting for the vegas
knights and then i don't know who i
would root for i would be really
happy to see the islanders win number
five
because when i really when i first
started walking watching hockey they
were the best team out there
and uh i loved mike bossie
i loved that guy i just loved the way he
played i just he one of the great
[ __ ] players of all time
um and clark gillies was the toughest
[ __ ]
ever um and then i love billy smith
i love the whole [ __ ] i just they were
just fun to [ __ ] watch
and uh so that would be cool but then
the vegas knights
it's great for hockey if a team this
early on has this level of success
it solidifies um
you know their fan base their fan base
has already gone through the heartbreak
of losing a game seven
in the finals did they lose that stanley
cup is it the final the finals i have no
idea
um so i think i would root islanders but
if it's islanders vegas i would be happy
for both um
tampa lightning i totally respect and
dallas stars of course too but i'm just
just being honest here all right that's
it go [ __ ] yourselves i'll check in on
you on thursday